لكن انا اتحدث عن نفوذ لهذه الجماعات حتى
بعد ان اعلن عمليه
حظرها من من عام 1923 حتى الان يعني ما
السبب في بقائها صلبه داخل المجتمع التركي
وهذه السياسه الرسميه لم تتغير ولكن
تركيا الى حكم الاحزاب متعدده في خمس قرار
الماضي يشاهدنا بروز ما يسمى
التناقض او او خاصه مختلفه لمنعتقل
النهائيه
والمحافظات همم غير الناميه هو هنالك حتى
رجال الدين الذي يقدمه الدعم لهذه
المنظمات
وينضمون اليها ولهذا السبب بشكل خاص فان
احزاب الجناحين اليمين والذين يحافظون على
جنده واضحه
يحاولون ان يعطوا الافضليه لهذه الجماعات
الدينيه وخاصه
جناح
الماضي
الماضيه اغلب الحكومه كانت يمنيه في هذه
البلاد بشكل اساسي
كان هناك يتسامح معها رايتنج
العداله والتنميه فان الجماعه ال جينيه هي
منظمات فعاله جدا اللي التقديم لان رسائل
وتعبير عنها ما المجتمعات وحتى لحج الاراء
لصالح هذه الاحزاب والفوز بالانتخابات
ولهذا السبب ومع مرور الوقت اثناء
اليمنيه
وحتى تسامحه وتسهلت مع تصرفاتها
بالمقابل هذه الجماعات الدينيه تحولت الى
جماعات المصالح الرئيسيه فهي الان المكون
الرئيسي همم لها ثقل كبير في الانتخابات
وكذلك جماعه همم
اه راعي الاحزاب اليمنيه حسب اجنداتها
السياسيه